y tenemos 0.79 o 79 centésimas menos
cuatro tercios menos un medio más 150%
ustedes están viendo que tenemos
distintos números en distintas formas de
representar los tenemos decimales
tenemos fracciones dos fracciones aquí y
también tenemos un número en porcentaje
si nosotros queremos hacer esta suma y
resta lo que realmente ocupamos es poner
todos los números digamos que en el
mismo lenguaje en la forma más sencilla
que a mí se me ocurre es convertir todas
las fracciones porque aquí por ejemplo
tendríamos un tercio más dos tercios más
tres tercios cuatro tercios y para
evitar con números repetitivos lo que
vamos a hacer es convertir todos estos
números tanto los decimales como las
fracciones y el porcentaje nos vamos a
convertir a un solo formato en este caso
fracciones
y tenemos 79 centésimos lo cual
significa 79 sobre 100 esto ya lo
conocemos por el valor de las posiciones
79 centésimos significa que está sobre
100 y también tenemos aquí menos cuatro
tercios que ya no ocupamos modificarlo
ya está en fracción tenemos un medio
menos un medio que de igual forma ya
está en fracción y tenemos también aquí
más 150% recuerden que el por ciento
significa por cada 100 lo que podemos
representar como 150
por cada 100 por ciento
ahora para que nosotros logremos hacer
estas sumas y estas restas de diferentes
fracciones ocupamos un denominador común
para todos y la forma en la que podemos
hacerlo es con un mínimo común múltiplo
buscaremos que el número que pueda ser
divisible entre 100 32 y 100 manuel 100
se nos repite
pensemos el 100 sin duda es un
denominador común ya que puede ser
dividido entre 2 sin embargo necesitamos
también que sea divisible entre 3 y 100
no es divisible entre 3 quedando el
enteros completos entonces vamos a hacer
algo el mínimo común denominador que yo
veo sería 300 así es que vamos a
convertir todo a un denominador de 300
para que esté 79 sobre 100 tenga un
denominador de 300 estoy multiplicando
el denominador por 3
y haré lo mismo con el numerador 79 por
380 por 3 es igual a 240 pero si le
quito 3 van a ser 237
menos
si este denominador lo quiero convertir
a 300 multiplicar por 100 entonces 3 por
100 es igual a 300 4 por 100 es igual a
menos
para convertir este 2 a 300
multiplicaré por 150 2 150 300 11 por
ciento cincuenta 150
y finalmente este último número para
tener el denominador de 300
lo multiplicaré por 3 100 por 3 300 150
por 3 400
50 y así ya tenemos todas nuestras
fracciones con un denominador común que
es 300 esto podemos escribirlo así
y ahora sí podremos entonces pensar en
hacer nuestras suma si nuestras restas
237 menos 400
- 150
más
450 estamos representando lo mismo de
este lado del signo y ahora sí podremos
hacer nuestra suma si nuestras restas
pensemos en esto
tenemos por aquí 1 - 400 y un menos 150
si estos dos los juntamos tendremos
menos
vamos bien solo sumamos estos dos ahora
tenemos este que es positivo 237 y este
450 que son positivos los dos podemos
hacer algo sumar estos dos positivos y
restar el 550 y yo veo aquí algo mucho
más sencillo 550 negativo más 450
positivo me va a dar igual a menos 100
y ahora si esto estuvo muchísimo más
sencillo 237 menos 100 es igual a 137
entre
300 como numerador nos quedará 137 y
como denominador nos quedará 300 ahora
si buscamos simplificar esto pensaríamos
en algún número que fuera divisible yo
realmente no veo ninguna otra forma en
la que el 137 se pueda dividir realmente
esta es la forma más pequeña con la que
logró obtener el número y por lo tanto
esta será nuestra respuesta
nos vemos en otro vídeo